we named the company innovate which
stands for innovation and video
for a reason because we always felt uh
um back then and still today our biggest
competitor is google google has a
division called doubleclick
and that's that's our uh main competitor
and almost all of our growth coming from
customers that are moving google and
shifting to innovate what will stop uh
google getting 100 of the best engineers
in the room and and changing and
rebuilding what you did
and and our answer is that we will
always win on innovation
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this is a very special episode it really
does embody what this show is all about
why do you do what you do what is
innovation what is creativity
please meet talkha luzine the co-founder
and cto of the amazing innovate a
connected tv and video advertising
platform for advertisers to engage
consumers across all screens and
channels
tal leads innovates long-term technology
vision global product creation and
implementation and business development
efforts as well as identifying and
developing emerging trends and
opportunities for product innovation and
digital tv or ott collaborations he has
forged partnerships with facebook
snapchats twitter samsung roku and hulu
amongst others to help advertisers bring
interactive video to viewers everywhere
tal is a serial entrepreneur and
tireless global leader in video
technology in addition to serving as
innovate cto paul is a board member for
the iab's digital video center of
excellence and for the national academy
of television arts and sciences he has
been named 2018 inductee in the american
advertising federation's advertising
hall of achievement for his significant
impact on the industry by a mentorship
inspiration volunteerism and training
previous accolades include being named a
technology pioneer by the world economic
forum one of the best young european
entrepreneurs by businessweek a member
of multi-channel news 40 under 40 class
of 2016 and to synopsis digital's 2016
eclipse
thank you tal for coming on this is
going to be a great episode
you're calling from new york right now
right the innovate offices there i am
awesome well according to linkedin you
have more than 500 people already i know
that's not always the most accurate but
but that is to say you've you've
co-founded 15 years ago a company that
that really is a game changer in the in
the video format and an advertisement
personalization space
i can only imagine what what was going
through your mind in 2007 you know when
when facebook was basically just
starting to take off and
and i'm trying to piece together sort of
the the different thesis that you must
have come up with to reach where you're
at today but but your personal journey
of innovation and entrepreneurship you
know goes far back to you know your days
in the israeli air force and garage geek
so so tal i'd love to spend a little bit
of time understanding your brain a
little bit better what you know who who
are you tall taking me back all the way
to the israeli air force days
well my wife's for many many years is
trying to understand the same thing so
uh
hopefully
exactly exactly
so uh yeah i guess you you covered all
uh all points i'll try to give uh to
give a short answer and throw it back to
you so uh as you said i'm told to losing
we started innovate about 15 years ago
with the
dream or division that television is
going to move to the internet um and
while moving to the internet a lot of
things will change specifically or
around how people consume television
will be more of a two-way communication
i'll hold an xbox remote or an
interactive remote and i can actually
click on things and the second um
because it runs on internet platforms
you can or interface you can do so many
more things like personalize the message
that everyone sees the right
ad
that is relevant for for them for their
households you can do much better
measurement and then marketers
don't need to spend so much and just
bombard the market with advertising
because each and every one of them can
work so much further
so that that's the general premise
little that we know about uh everything
that's gonna happen around the
transformation into streaming uh
streaming devices and apps and netflix
and
um disney plus and so many of those
clearly did not exist
but you you wanted to start even even uh
a couple years before at uh the earth or
so
um
uh i was in my program um
uh after graduating high school and then
i chose to join the air force
in the air force i was back then there
was a unit called mondas now it's uh
changed to be called offic
which is um
the unit that
makes most of the operational software
for the air force so embedded software
for for planes and helicopters and uh
ammunition and other things and command
and control software
um i was on that team
uh as a developer then a team leader uh
and then i was in the
general architecture team
uh across um
uh across the air force uh building some
of those some of the system i ended up
staying for quite some time about eight
years
uh really enjoying uh that world uh it's
pretty fascinating that you as a kid i
don't know 19 years old
can uh deal with uh
a pretty cool software uh that
there's you can argue if you like the
use of that software or not that was
some of the reasons why i ended up
leaving but uh but still at a very young
age you can lead a team uh and build
something that is very impactful uh very
complicated uh and very very rigorous
and in a very
advanced system
um
again stayed there learned uh learned a
ton and met a lot of amazing people that
are still
one of my closest friends
um
but uh maybe at the tail end uh of my
serve and in the air force uh i was
doing a lot of work around video
processing
uh and then i just became curious about
um what can software back then no one
used terms like machine learnings or
artificial intelligence but uh this is
again 2006 ish um but uh but the general
idea that we can process video and
insert elements into into the video
uh you know the same idea that you watch
a soccer match and then there's some
drawing on the video or there is uh
they're uh even commercial they're
superimposed on the sides sure of or the
actual lawn or the grass um
uh so we thought we if you if you can do
that maybe uh maybe you can create
better better video experience and
that's just to take you to that time
that was the time when when youtube
started
uh kind of emerging this was the time
that google acquired youtube and it was
kind of clear that there's some form of
a video creation revolution and we
wanted to be part of that
and but that your sort of your way of
thinking spans
beyond just this you know you founding
co-founding garage geeks and you know
your work you know in innovation tell me
a little bit about that because i'm
curious about the transition from
you know developer team leader
transitioning to an innovator and and
what that what that requires of your
creativity what that requires of
leadership style and and where did you
get you know hooked onto that
uh those are all big words uh i i
wouldn't i wouldn't describe myself in
any of them but
i'll just say that um it's more about
curiosity uh than anything so garage
gigs is a place we started
uh right in cologne in israel uh in a
real uh garage that um
was uh zika my partner's uh um family
owned this uh
uh
uh this place in a very random area of
coulomb and what we wanted to do is we
love playing xbox and we don't like
drinking beer and we said there may be
other people uh that that have the same
passion and they don't really have a
place to go that is like we used to call
it a man or a woman club for for geeks
uh so it started with this idea of okay
let's all meet together play video games
and talk about electronics robotics uh
and other things literally for exactly
as i said for for
uh souls sake of curiosity so something
very important and we said that from day
one is that it's not for commercials we
don't want to be the place that uh
i don't know a startup incubator or a
place for matchmaking of founders that
this was definitely not the idea the
idea is that if you're curious about
technology you're curious about it could
be even music or or other elements um
but if you're very curious about it for
true curiosity and and your passion to
learn
maybe you can meet
like-minded people and just
geek on it um and that's literally how
it started uh we started just throwing
events and then we became very close
friends with jose vardy uh who really
helped propel
that place to the next level
under the again the premise that there
are quite a lot of people that are
curious in israel coming from very
different disciplinaries uh and they
just wanna wanna meet together uh i
started by by talking playing video
games and drinking beer and then we we
did a lot more events um and uh teaching
people to hack
a wii console
uh all the way to
i don't know making electronic music
and building
um robots that play guitar hero and xbox
on xbox or many other things uh and it
was something that really uh we're
really passionate about and you can tie
a lot of it to innovate as well is the
the connection or the place where where
art means meet technology
um so a lot of the things that we
created was was kind of artistic in
nature but uh but heavily focused on uh
on technology and you asked about why
uh why at least what what drove me to be
excited about this is more about the the
idea with what when i discovered
this cool thing is that you can go in
the internet and i literally knew
nothing about electronics but i can go
on youtube or wikipedia or other places
and order
um different electronic components over
over the internet and just watch youtube
videos and then build robots
and this was just and again i knew
nothing i
barely finished my high school i never
went to study uh
any undergrad let alone grad grad
students but uh
and i just i was mostly mesmerized about
the ease that you can actually make
things happen
incredible i i have to say i share i
share a very similar passion and many
years later i i got to take part in in
mahanetta's the as the organizer from
the shimano times side
and so i i that that also helped me fall
in love with the uselessness nature of
simply geeking out
my my invention was building a robot
that can make a pancake so it wasn't
completely useless even the head of the
police force enjoyed our pancakes uh i i
don't promise it was tasty but it was
but but i can definitely resonate a lot
with with the nature of how you're
thinking through things
so we're in 2006 and back to innovate a
little bit
you're realizing that we're in the
middle of the creator transformation the
way people consume media is going to
change dramatically
do do you realize that it's going to
take on multiple revolutions and and we
still don't know where yet where we're
at right i mean it could we could be
seeing another revolution you know soon
with a metaverse et cetera but
how are you thinking through this world
of media back in 2006
so i must say again coming from very
naive uh and now it's very easy to say
that and sounds uh sounds poetic but uh
but it is very this is literally how it
was we came from a truly naive approach
that we never even tried to predict
where the future will be the one thing
we knew is that
uh we all lived in a world pre-iphone
and post iphone 3 facebook or social
network uh and post social networking
and same thing about just generally the
internet and we just felt that
those
massive uh technological inventions just
changed the world so much that you
cannot predict
what the world would look like but you
do know that you will be very different
uh and a lot of the kind of underpinning
capabilities will change but the
consumption of media uh or experiencing
content and extreme experience in movies
or news or sports or reality doesn't
matter well everyone would still enjoy
that but everything around it the user
experience the accessibility the
discovery sharing all of that will
change massiveness so we never thought
to even imagine what the future would
look like we just felt like oh it's
going to change massively
it's going to be over the internet it's
going to be software powered we just
said we want to insert ourselves in
there
and let's just start a journey this is
literally how we did and raise our
around without really knowing what we're
about to do just under the belief that
it's going to change the software will
play a big role we want to be there
kind of smack in the middle uh building
that uh building that's also so we
started with
again heavy on the creative side of
allowing we called it power to the
producers uh so allowing youtubers
creating interactive video and allowing
people create really cool
um music videos
um and i remember like back in 2008 or
so we did uh some partnership with uh
um some canadian studio that produced um
live band kind of
shows
uh and broadcast them all over the
internet and they had a lot of sponsors
that want to insert themselves into the
message but they wanted to do it in a
fun way so we created things that you
can insert logos in a really cool way uh
um on this on the stage itself can
superimpose so it's not really an ad but
something that this the stage is
sponsored by mazda back then um but in a
nice way or a movie by
warner brothers um or you can play games
like trivia while watching the show
about the band and it's all kind of
yeah in between there it weaved
different brand messages so this is what
uh what we did at the beginning then the
the internet the online video youtube
started to take off so we realized that
uh maybe we're onto something so we can
build build other things
and then innovate that is today
uh was foreign with different software
platforms for large marketers uh which
is
uh how do you how do you manage how you
as procter gamble or target or microsoft
or very large brands manage when you
stream your ads on youtube on hulu on
disney on soon netflix on
espn many other places in 100 countries
you need a centralized system that
manage everything
um and you need a centralized system
that you see all of your data in monthly
this is what what we do right now right
so i guess one of the big one of the
opportunities if you've realized is that
sort of the change in the market is that
if before people were advertising just
in several
mainstream channels so you know you
could manage it probably within an excel
or notebook etc today we have so many
different platforms and so many
different and even data points that even
just being able to standardize the data
and being able to to to see it from all
the channels that's
you know just one big headache for
anybody right
yeah 100
it's super fragmented from so many
different ways
um and and yes how do you
how do you as a as a company stay ahead
of the game um you know a few hundred
people already
how do you you know you're talking about
an industry that is changing so quickly
i i didn't i didn't even i i couldn't
even realize what tick-tock was before
it took over the world seriously how do
you as a company manage to constantly be
ahead of the game to to understand the
different trends different platforms and
different consumer behaviors
okay
so uh just in terms of data points you
you mentioned few hundred people so
innovative 600 people right now
um who made a big acquisition about 150
people
of a company called tv squared
earlier this year so that kind of bumped
up the numbers
um
how do we stay ahead
uh so we named the company innovate
which stands for innovation and video
for a reason because we always felt uh
um back then and still today our biggest
competitor is google google has a
division called doubleclick um and
that's that's our uh main competitor and
almost all of our growth coming from
customers that are moving google and
shifting to innovate and we always felt
you know there's this vc question for a
round entrepreneurs are always asked
what will stop uh google getting a
hundred of the best engineers in the
room and and changing and rebuilding
what you did
and and our answer is that we will
always win on innovation
uh because we think that all of the big
companies will never be in the forefront
we'll always seek
um
sick revenue and we'll seek only mature
and and stable industries and we said no
we think that uh because we're
passionate about the creative and the
change of the industry uh we
we put innovation as a core tenant of
everything that we do
uh so we
from the beginning we always try to
guess
where the market is going back in 2014
we assumed that they would be streaming
the television will be streamed and we
met this very young company called roku
that they just started
and they hired their first person wow
who did something in advertising and i
became very close personal friend with
that person it's called rosenberg uh and
then we
just i remember until today we had a
whiteboard session say like oh this
maybe someday people will disconnect
their cable and will stream television
let's start building that right now and
we said we will put engineers on it even
we have no clue when it will start
making money
uh and we signed our first deal that
roku ever did wow and since we did so
many things together incredible and so
you know as a leader and as a technology
leader within this organization
you know are there specific things that
you realize that you do
you know in in a leadership standpoint
that helped foster innovation or help
enable a you know you're mentioning this
decision to put engineers on something
that may not amount to anything right
that that's a bold move but how do you
how do you get people within your
organization to
be thinking in that same mindset and
take risks in a world where if you take
the wrong risks in mid level management
you may not do well
yeah so clearly we still manage a
business so i just want to put it in
context that it's not that we just uh
constantly navigate the whole company
sure sure to do things that we have no
clue if they will um of course of course
they will mature but uh but i think um
so far
uh every customer that we won uh and we
moved off of google for example uh
we just reported by the way we took the
company public at the beginning at the
end of last year
exchange under the ticker ctv
and uh
we
uh just reported in our last uh turning
that we are uh
general motors who's uh one of google's
largest customer if not the largest uh
advertising customer on google platforms
uh decided to move to innovate and and
when we interview a customer after every
win what made you choose innovate is
that everyone is saying literally till
today with hundreds of customers is that
relentless focus on innovation
and uh the belief
that uh we want to build a future-proof
platform uh this is what drove them to
uh to move to
so we invest
in the grand scheme of things small
percentage of our over r d and product
resources in that but we take it
seriously yes we um we believe that
television will be will have commerce in
it and people could could buy things
with the remote so we're saying okay we
have the power right now to work with
the world's largest advertisers in
almost every country and do trials maybe
no one would actually buy anything but
let's do that i love that uh we so all
of those things and you asked about how
do we uh tell people to take those risks
we just show
that it's not you do not need to chase
the exact dollars but uh kind of derived
dollars actually comes along so again
general motors chose innovate and this
is many many millions of dollars of a
customer
um
and they chose it because of their
belief in innovation even if they don't
really pay the dollars for that they end
up buying the standard product but what
drove them to innovate is that they
think that yeah innovation is something
that they want to be associated
incredible i love that tal this is such
a
such an enjoyable conversation and going
all the way back to you know where where
innovation
stems from now you did mention the
beginning that's it's a very large word
it's a very fluffy word i i i don't like
those either but i think that
knowing you know some of the experiences
that you've had having gone through them
myself some of them you you started
yourself and i i appreciate the the
simplicity behind what what innovation
is and the uselessness nature of of
being a geek and trying out things and
seeing how things work and and just you
know taking the time to to study
something try it out get excited by by
doing something that somebody else has
done but doing it yourself and and then
seeing where things go and so i'm
not surprised at all not surprised at
all by what you and your co-founders
have done here which is really inspiring
and remarkable so thank you for your
time and for your energy and i can't
wait to continue seeing the amazing ways
you're going to be working in the media
space thank you
so much thank you true pleasure
[Music]